monsters have been part of storytelling
for pretty much as long as there have
been stories one of the oldest known
stories today is the epic of gilgamesh
who has to face a terrifying demon in
order to gain access to a forbidden
forest this hasn't changed today and we
are still fascinated by these monsters
maybe even more so than ever they
represent our greatest fears and embody
the dread we feel in the face of evil
and catastrophe
monsters allow us to visualize these
fears and help us deal with them more
easily
this usually plays out in either one of
two ways option 1 the hero and the
monster fight until one of them is
defeated this can for example be seen in
stories like Harry Potter where the
mystery and terror of the monster
steadily grow until it is finally
defeated option to basically twists this
common expectation and upon
confrontation the monster turns out to
be an ally or not even a monster after
all a great example of this is King Kong
a giant terrifying gorilla that ends up
protecting the humans on his island the
world of one piece is no different and
is filled with countless evils and
monsters itself that the straw hat crew
either has to face in battle or ends up
fighting alongside with there is one
very special case in the story though
that takes a very different approach to
the concept of the monster I think it is
fair to say that chopper is one of the
more overlooked members of luffy's crew
which is surprising because being a
reindeer that ate the human human fruit
and that ended up becoming a sweet
loving doctor in many ways makes him the
most fantastical nakami
on the ship and yet despite of this
bizarre and extremely unique character
concept chopper ended up getting less
and less attention by the readers as
time passed and as we will find out
later there is one big problem with
choppers writing that I believe takes a
lot of tension out of his character and
it is not what you think it is because
for many people it seems that chopper
has been turned into a sort of cute
mascot for the crew but even if Oda has
deliberately turned chopper into an
obvious piece of kauai merchandise he's
still a well-set-up
and natural feeling character in the way
he's presented in the story as a matter
of fact
I will argue that chopper has the most
complete character arc out of all the
straw hat so far therefore in this video
we are going to look at why al
cotton-candy loving reindeer is a great
example of excellent character writing
how his development arc is different
from the other straw hats and where
owner might have made one big mistake so
who is chopper and what qualifies him to
be a straw hat we first get to meet Tony
Tony chopper on drum island shortly
after entering the grant line chopper
grew up as a reindeer in the mountains
of the island where he was treated as an
outcast by his herd and even his parents
because of his big nose when he later
ate the human human fruit and suddenly
acquired human-like intelligence he was
banished completely from his herd when
trying to communicate with the humans of
the islands he was called a monster
chased away and badly wounded finally he
was taken in by the good-hearted doctor
here look who took care of chopper and
inspired him to become a doctor when he
looks health worsened significantly over
time though chopper set out to find a
cure for his newfound father figure
during his search he encounters his old
hurt once more and is forced to fight
the leader he manages to win but is
heavily wounded in the process again and
after he makes it back to the house
barely alive out of sheer gratefulness
here Luke eats the mushroom that chopper
has found well knowing it contains a
deadly poison
he later tragically commits suicide to
not burden his son with being the reason
for his death after this once again
major blow of Destiny chopper is then
taken in by dr. kuraha who tells him the
truth about the deadly mushroom but then
goes on to take him in and teach him
real medicine in the isolation of a
castle what this shows us right from the
beginning is that chopper has basically
been an outcast for all of his life
until he meets Luffy he's a reindeer and
a human and yet seems to be accepted by
neither both have shown him nothing but
violence and hatefulness in the end
chopper grew up with the impression of
being an abnormally a monster that
doesn't have a place in society
considering that he's only 15 when
joining the crew I would argue that this
counts as a truly tragic backstory as
of this we get introduced to Chiapas
character having a couple of clear
weaknesses he has a clear lack of self
confidence is very shy and has serious
trust issues he also is terribly ashamed
and afraid of his devil fruit powers
giving a character a set of well
explained and compelling weaknesses is
important in order to make the
development arc interesting and
plausible it helps the reader to
identify and empathize with the
character and create a story that feels
natural and close to reality in Choppers
case one could say that he starts off as
a timid and naive teenager that has gone
through a horrendous childhood if
monsters are the embodiment of our fears
then Chapa may be best embodies our fear
of not knowing who we are and where we
belong I would say that this is best
symbolized by his monster point
something he can control and fears after
joining Luffy and the crew he becomes
the ship's doctor making him one of the
main characters of the story his great
medical knowledge puts the reindeer in
maybe one of the most important roles on
board
but besides having to stitch together
Luffy every other Island chopper also
has a bunch of other abilities and
powers that make him unique in the crew
being one of the devil fruit uses on the
crew he is also the only zone type on
the ship this gives him the ability to
fight even though his insecurity and
lack of combat experience seemed to put
him in the lower tiers of the crew in
that regard amazingly enough though
Chapo was able to use his medical
knowledge to create his rumble bolts
that allow him to control and expand his
devil fruit transformation to a certain
extent something that even dr. Vega
Punk's seems to have failed to achieve
especially in OneNote that has a heavy
focus on zone type devil fruits it will
be interesting to see whether this will
play a major role in the story at some
point
lastly being an animal himself chopper
is able to communicate with other
animals which on occasions has proven to
be quite useful to the crew over the
course of their journey closely
connected to chopper skills and history
are also the values that Oda has
attributed to his character over the
course of the journey we can clearly see
that he values kindness and friendship
deeply
that intensifies when traveling with the
crew having trained under two
kind-hearted doctors chopper also
strongly values science and beliefs in
its good nature in accordance with this
he also holds the belief that the
doctors duty is to help and save anyone
this set of values fit in smoothly with
the rest of the character making his
action seem authentic and natural
furthermore having a character with a
clear set of values is important in
order to test these values in the
confrontation with those of an opponent
all of the straw hats are kind and while
this kindness is often tested by the
cruelty and evil a encounter in the
world in chiapas case in particular it
is his belief in science that is
challenged especially his encounters
with Hogback and Caesar are especially
interesting because they also value
science but for different reasons giving
a character an opponent who values the
same thing but from a different
viewpoint usually makes for the most
interesting conflicts and plot points
like any other major character based on
these values and his backstory choppa
also has a desire a desire is something
that the character sets out to fulfill
over the course of the story in the
context of one piece this is nothing
else than the notorious dream that every
straw had has due to his medical
education and his good heart
choppers dream is to make the world a
better place by becoming a doctor that
can cure any disease especially in the
new world we have come across a wide
range of diseases that would pose a real
opportunity for chopper to prove his
skill finally based on his tragic past
and the resulting weaknesses for
choppers character out of this we now
have to look at the psychological need
that he has to satisfy over the course
of the story you can think of the
psychological need as a serious flaw
that is hurting our character in some
significant way and is holding him back
the psychological need is something that
any developing and interesting character
should have it is something that
alongside the desire drives the
characters arc under the surface until
he realizes it is a problem sooner or
later in Choppers case this need is laid
out very clearly by Oda in the store
chopper needs to learn to accept and
believe in himself his lack of
confidence and identity not only heard
him emotionally but also hold him back
in doing what he wants to do and keep
him from being happy when he joins the
straw hats on that journey he also goes
on a journey to satisfy this need this
is the premise for his character arc I
think we can agree that this setup makes
a lot of sense considering his backstory
and how his character was introduced to
us and yet Oda has made a grave mistake
here and that mistake I've come to
believe might be the reason that chopper
appears as uninteresting to many readers
compared to the other straw hats because
as we have learned the psychological
need is something affecting the
character himself in some significant
way this creates a clear path for
development and gives the character a
goal that neither he nor the reader
might be aware of at the beginning what
makes the character and as a result the
plot surrounding him a lot more
interesting though is a need that also
affects and hurts those around him in
some significant way of form a great
example of how this might work is for
example whose ops in security not only
did it badly affect himself but he also
heard those around him when deciding to
leave the crew you can call this the
moral need of a character and you will
find it in most of your favorite figures
in any story the big problem with
chopper is he doesn't have one Oda has
written choppers neat in a way that
makes him struggle all within himself
his timid nature keeps him from
projecting his insecurities on others
this makes for a very decent person but
for weak a plot which is a pity because
initially Oda actually gave chopper this
hostility towards people but chiapas ill
feelings towards Luffy and Nami lasted
only for a couple of chapters and it
didn't hurt either 'z feelings
in other words chopper lacks an Musab
moment a situation in which he actively
hurt others and as a result had to deal
with the consequences
instead chopper struggle is all on the
inside now as I've mentioned before
chopper is still an amazing and
well-written character but I think that
this lack of a moral need in his
development arc is the main reason
people tend to have a problem with him
or downgrade
- nothing more than a mascot especially
because most of the other straw hats
have been given a moral need by Oda so
now that we have looked at how odor has
created chopper we of course also want
to understand how his character has
changed over the course of the story
developing and changing a character is
essential in order to keep him relevant
and interesting to the story and to give
the reader a sense of time flow and
impact in regard to the plot that being
set change doesn't always equal good
change for example simply making a
character stronger or change his
appearance will not give the reader any
sense of fulfilment true change involves
a challenging and changing of basic
beliefs in other words it means taking
the initial weakness and need of the
character and then changing them by
making the character go through certain
actions and situations
Chapas character arc therefore aims at
changing his lack of self-confidence his
trust issues as well as his Nativity and
shyness there are certain categories of
change in storytelling and one that
applies best to Chopper in my mind is
dead of a child changing into an adult
in other words challenging his beliefs
and finding his place in the world on
his journey to define himself he sees
almost anyone on the crew as a role
model the more time he spends with the
crew the more accepted and valued choppa
felt so much so that upon the reunion
after the time-skip
choppa was finally able to completely
leave his characterization as a freak
behind the initial mix between his kind
and undeniably cute personality and his
existence as a kind of biological
abomination makes this change the more
interesting in my eyes after time-skip
however this monster chopper is replaced
almost entirely by the cotton candy
lover chopper he is no longer portrayed
as a frightening freak of nature and
even the literal monster point has been
tamed down and even if you might find
monster chopper cool on the surface
though sweet chopper truly is the
natural progression of his character
after fully putting the pain of his past
behind him there has always been an
underlying sweet element to monster
chopper and his development across the
series is an uplifting story of him
becoming comfortable
enough with himself through the help of
his friends to allow the cotton candy to
overtake the beast
what makes this monster story so
different from others is that chopper
doesn't have to choose between being
human or being a monster anymore
he was able to accept who he is and
still find his place in the world being
accepted by his friends this becomes
very clear on Fishman Island when
chopper transformed into his human point
Sanji points out how he doesn't even
look human anymore - which chopper
responds that he is a monster now so
what can we derive from this chopper has
apparently been able to change his
shyness and insecurities into confidence
and positivity he is no longer fighting
with his identity and has also found
friends that accept him just the way he
is I would argue at this point that
chopper as the only straw hat so far has
completed an entire character arc until
the time skip and that has two major
implications on the one hand I think it
shows us that chopper is a great
character same as many others I greatly
enjoyed him up until the time skip and I
hope you can see now why on the other
hand though a completed character arc
with no new psychological or moral need
has rendered choppa meaningless in the
new world until whole cake island that
is and here my hopes have been going up
immensely lately because after leaving
zou to go and save Sanji together with
luffy chopper finally seems to have
started a new development arc after
completing his change from child to
adult i think we can now see clear signs
that chopper is starting to change from
an adult to a leader at this point a
quick warning if you don't want to be
spoiled for whole cake island or wanna
just skip ahead a bit now ready okay the
first instance of this new character arc
we can see in chiapas relationship with
carrot in which he takes the role of the
big brother this puts him in the
situation to guide and take care of
someone for the very first time but also
the way he acts in whole cake islands
supporting luffy smartly and being an
asset much rather than a hindrance shows
us that something is going on here
chopper takes the initiative more and
more the latest example of this is the
amazing job he did in guiding the
yong-chol big moe
- Adan prison - breakout Luffy after her
memory loss I would go so far as to say
that choppers new need might be that of
lacking leadership qualities and he's
slowly working towards gaining them I
definitely have high hopes for our
reindeer and I truly hope that he will
get the character arc that he truly
deserves I think that Chopper has so
much more potential than simply being a
mascot he is one of the best monsters in
storytelling after all a cotton candy
monster hey everybody thank you so much
for watching before you run off and get
yourself some cotton candy
I would first love to hear your opinion
on Chopper do you think he's an
interesting character or not and why so
and where do you see his character art
going in the future
as always Shay thoughts in the comments
below at this point I also want to thank
my patreon supporters your pledges mean
a lot to me if you are interested in
helping me make more and better videos
you can find the link to my page in the
description below you will get free
access to all of my artwork and early
access to my major videos thanks for
your support also if you like this video
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to be notified for any future content of
mine or dislike don't share and
unsubscribe it's a free world people I
hope to see you around next time and
until then have a great week oh yeah and
don't forget to turn your notifications
on YouTube can sometimes be forgetful by
you
[Music]